[Music]
my sister is very pregnant
um she's due in like a month
so that's pretty cool next time I see
her she's going to have a child
little cousins and we started getting
like
we started getting like diapers and I
set up a [__] stroller this weekend
nice I feel like just like such a what
for you yeah for me or for us yeah just
felt like such a cliche
looking at the instructions
sitting there like I can't [__]
figure out how to put this thing
together yeah like sweating trying to
put the like I'm just straight from a
[__] movie about someone having their
first kid well strap in dude because I
can tell you this about um setting up
children's toys and products
that's that's gonna be me mine's kind of
a [__] Hemi in the back
because I hear you're gonna mod the
scooter yeah
I was setting up a little castle for our
friend's daughter's birthday
and they're explaining to me
that no kids toys having like for the
most part kids products they're made
pretty cheaply so they just never have
instructions yeah so half your time is
just figuring out some [__] yeah
sitting on the floor yeah what the [__]
is yeah I can't yeah that's exactly what
it was and it was like this is one of
the best strollers I'm pretty sure you
can get they send it to us and
I couldn't figure out the instructions
so I'd like look up a YouTube video yeah
on how to do it and they had made like a
YouTube short but it was like for an
older version of the stroller uh so I'm
like cross-referencing that with the
instructions with the current version
that I have right it was a nightmare
dude hour I spent an hour I'm just gonna
get like I'm Gonna Fill Up Like A Home
Depot bucket with silly putty
like a gel okay and then I'm just gonna
weld like a simple series of bars
to like some shopping cart wheels and
I'll just stick my kid in the jelly just
a perfect sound and it'll just be like
chess level so my kill just being there
it was good talking to JT yesterday
because he has two yeah you got two of
them two kids two he had twins he got a
twofer and he's like yeah dude it's like
we're he's had them for now for like
three weeks or something yeah he's like
I got the routine down he's like I like
to treat it like uh like a race like in
the morning like I change them I feed
them I get them in there like I swaddle
them I get them in the you know the snoo
or whatever and they just nap yeah he's
like as long as I do those four things
or five things or whatever in that order
like I'm good yeah
like that's good I like I like that yeah
pretty like a game I'm jealous man
that's what I'm trying to do I'm trying
to get a twofer I know I'm not gonna I
kind of I kind of was hoping that it was
twins when we first found out I'd be
like I would like to have twins I think
that'd be cool I'm not gonna nut for a
year I'm gonna try to just I'm trying to
get as many of them [__] in
there how it works isn't it like two of
them getting the same hatch yeah but
it's not because you come more it could
work I don't know I'm not I'll actually
I'll probably do that and I'll probably
this is so graphic
let's use a theoretical man wait a year
to nut and then he goes to nut it's just
like it's all like coagulated yeah it's
just Mixed Concrete in there
so he goes to none it's just like a
brick that just slides out yeah
wow I feel sick
I wanna puke
yeah and then just I'm coming out
yeah you can choose to have twins if you
do IVF yes you can do that yeah but
aren't people against like IVF they say
like you should let Darwin like do its
thing
which is crazy that's stupid
um yeah
and then I was looking at what what type
of requests can you make with IVF
because we were joking that it's more
but it's not that much it's just eye
color and gender oh okay yeah and
whether it's Twins or not yeah
yeah
Chrissy Teigen like I think they tried
to have a kid and she had a miscarriage
or something like that
so then she was like I don't want to get
pregnant again just in case I can't like
just in case my body I can't handle it
anymore right so they did a surrogate
yeah and then she got pregnant again and
they both were pregnant kind of at the
same time and she was able to have like
a full-term pregnancy so she had it she
they basically had two kids at the same
time that aren't twins kind of cool
right interesting yeah
yeah I'm just trying to get a two for
you know two for one and then just one
and done that'd be sick if it was just
one and done yeah call quits yep because
Elena and I will jokingly be Petty about
sharing like sodas and stuff and Alina
gets really specific about things like
if she pours a soda do not sip from her
soda okay she wants to know that she
drank one soda okay and if I [__] around
and [__] up the sips she feels like now
I have to go get a half can
she's very particular about soda okay
and I was laughing at her because we'll
do this we'll be in restaurants I might
sip out of her Coke because I'm waiting
for mine and she'll be like bro
please
and I'll laugh like okay my bad my bad
so then my dream actually would be to
have two girls
so then it's the three of them
and I get to [__] with all their sips
yeah or conversely they [__] with her
sips okay because if one of the if they
take after me and I'm like it's family
sips who cares we just get more Cokes
yeah then I turn the two of them against
her ah I see that'd be me and the girls
so this is all a sip battle yeah yeah
it's a battle of this hit yeah I think
it'd be so funny if it's me and like our
two five-year-olds and I'm like can't be
mean to them
stupid
does she sip out of yours she will and I
don't care
so that's kind of hypocritical she
doesn't she doesn't oh I see no let me
rephrase she will if I gesture but she
doesn't invite her she doesn't okay I
see but you know I'm just like a dog off
its leash I see DC or Coke Zero yeah you
know me I do that with food yeah I'm in
there yeah yeah with people I don't even
know yeah excuse me yeah yeah let me get
up let me get some of that yeah so
that's my master plan whatever kids we
have
or the funniest would be as if
whatever kids we have take after her
with the sips and then I'm just
terrorizing all of them yeah yeah
[Laughter]
I imagine one of them like pouring a
full glass of soda and like turning
around and putting in the fridge and you
like
pop up from underneath the cabinet and
like drink three quarters of it yeah
back down that's definitely and they
turn back around they're like what the
[__] yeah yeah I'll [__] I'll [__] with
Elena too when we work out because
she'll fill up her water I'll go I
forgot my and I'll just pretend to reach
for it it should be on the treadmill
she'll go no no no
so then I go outside and drink from the
hose like a dog
yeah
anytime Elena doesn't let me sip I just
turn on the sprinklers and I go out
front and embarrass her
and she's out there she's like oh honey
and then people walk by she's like my
husband loves the water
hey get inside
and I perfectly four-legged crawl back
into the house exactly
you had a kid thing
everybody's doing it the kids
everybody's doing it yeah everyone we
know
yeah it's gonna be a crazy few months we
have a couple months left
yeah
count it down as an independent adult
scared before I'm before I'm constantly
gonna be like this where's the yeah you
know yeah am I scared no not yet but I
think I will be but I'm not yet I'm
excited you gotta love your kid
regardless of what it likes yeah you
know if your kid's like I like you know
Daddy I like you you hakushin you're
like oh what is that anime okay
look dad can I get a Crunchyroll
subscription
I love wet it
is
can you buy me a fedora no no son no I
can't